vous avez des petits enfants ou pas oui
5 d'accord vous avez les prénoms
[Applaudissements]
de Pâques pour les élèves du lycée
professionnel Maria de Rennes dans le
17e arrondissement de Paris une rentrée
perturbée par un geste celui d'un
professeur contractuel d'anglais Victor
hymorino a mis le feu au 63 copies
d'examens de ses élèves de Bac
Professionnel en trois ans j'ai vu que
ça servait à rien ce qu'on faisait en
classe plus particulièrement en cours
d'anglais
[Musique]
Gims
[Applaudissements]
et
superveco et maintenant et maintenant
Gilbert Bécaud et maintenant Gilbert
ils sont forts ces arabes moi je
recharge régulièrement ma voiture
électrique sur les pyramides directement
de mais depuis des millénaires des
ancêtres étaient électriciens c'est
absolument absolument on voit des élèves
qui ont passé 7 ans dans le système et
qui sont pas capables d'aligner deux
mots correctement donc à un moment faut
se poser la question peut-être que c'est
le système le problème c'est un peu
cliché mais c'est vrai moi le premier
objectif de ce geste c'est d'annuler
l'épreuve telle manière à ce que il
n'est pas à avoir notre catastrophique
liée à leur épreuve du bac et en même
temps c'est pour vraiment dire que le
bac s'est dépassé faut une enseignante a
choisi une méthode d'encouragement assez
peu conventionnelle pour aider l'un de
ses élèves à réussir un examen elle lui
a promis un rencard avec lui s'il
réussissait ah visiblement cette
technique devrait être utilisée plus
souvent car l'élève a brillamment réussi
son examen de mathématiques et a donc
obtenu son date comme promis
champion Emily il faut marquer ce serait
dommage d'avoir enquillé les victoires
de duel pour chuter là maintenant à 2
mètres des 7000 euros oui mais je suis
heureuse j'ai vos boules
[Applaudissements]
d'après le nom d'un célèbre bar de
Montréal comment sont les foufounes
électrique le fait de balancer du
poisson frais ça change c'est assez cool
en sensation c'est à dire que je
connaissais même pas station au toucher
avec le film et ce petit moelleux là au
toucher franchement ça rappelle des
choses que j'ai pas envie de dire ici
mais bon c'est agréable les beignets il
y a que 5 minutes de spectacle de
Jean-Marie Bigard
selon une experte en relation amoureuse
l'odeur des beignets rendrai
immédiatement séduisant exactement 15
ans et demi
et comme j'étais pas très bon en
mathématiques ma mère m'avait demandé de
trouver un prof et cette prof donnait en
plus des cours qui a donné au lycée des
cours chez elle donc je suis allé une
fois deux fois trois fois et qu'est-ce
que tu racontes toi je peux raconter une
histoire je te jure sur la tête de mes
coucougnettes que c'est vrai
et je connais des coucougnettes et des
caftanes
voilà et donc voilà donc j'ai eu une
aventure pendant quelques semaines avec
cette jeune personne en fait elle se
base sur une étude selon laquelle
l'odeur du beignet augmenterait le flux
sanguin vers le pénis de écouter bien
31,5% ce qui explique sans doute comment
le donut a été créé
[Rires]
aimes-tu de rire je peux mourir à cet
instant précis je pense que vous serez
d'accord avec moi la clé c'est
l'éducation musicale des enfants alors
les enfants sont peut-être un peu jeunes
pour les Revol livres ils vont demander
des mots à leurs parents ça va mal finir
mais heureusement il y a une littérature
jeunesse là-dessus qui est foisonnante
ces derniers jours un collège d'Alsace
est au cœur de l'actualité au cours d'un
atelier cinéma des élèves de 6e était
censés visionner le film Tom boy un long
métrage sorti en 2011 qui pose la
question du genre dans lequel un enfant
né sous le prénom de l'or se présente
sous celui de Michael
pourquoi tu as fait ça mais les parents
d'élèves ont accusé ce film de pouvoir
mettre en danger le développement
psychologique de leur enfant
l'établissement catholique a donc décidé
d'annuler la diffusion pour ne pas créer
davantage de problèmes Monseigneur Joly
est l'un des tous premiers prêtres à
avoir reçu sa carte d'identification
avec
QR code il suffit de le flasher la carte
s'appelle un célébrette permettant
désormais de savoir si un prêtre est
sous le coup de restriction
et on arrive à une page qui est
finalement mon célèbre la couleur verte
qui dit que effectivement je suis
habilité à célébrer si la couleur est
rouge il n'a pas le droit d'exercer s'il
est orange il y a des restrictions comme
par exemple ne pas être seul avec des
mineurs
ce film mais quand des parents ont un
choix de mettre un collège catholique je
pense avec je pense avec des avec des
convictions
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
avec certaines convictions que je ne
partage pas forcément je comprends pas
tu as dit qu'à toi la même chose mais tu
m'arrêtes tout le temps sur le bouquin
justement vous assumez tout l'anus
dilaté comme jamais le fait de sortir en
roman dans un contexte hyper tendu et
les engueulades du président de la
République aussi j'imagine oui je fume
tout je le revendique même la NASA
prévoit un retour sur la lune d'ici
quelques années et les premiers pas sur
Mars à la fin de la décennie 2030 mais
certains comme ilon musk veulent voir
les choses en beaucoup plus grand le
multimilliardaire de SpaceX veut amener
un million de colons sur Mars d'ici 2050
et construire de véritables cités dômes
sur la planète rouge
le prototype de ces colonies martiennes
existe déjà justement ici à l'université
d'Arizona il s'appelle biosphère II une
micro terre sous cloche
[Musique]
la question du genre
écoute vu la prestation que tu as fait
ferme ta gueule ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
le minimum de dignité
en 1991 8 hommes et femmes se sont
enfermés pendant deux ans dans cette
planète miniature la mission fut riche
d'enseignement pour montrer les limites
du modèle l'équipage se fractura en deux
groupes opposés et les ressources
s'épuisèrent bien plus vite que prévu
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]